all right everyone we are doing the one
ship challenge today this is a box that
is also a coffin
I have maliciously recruited ha ha ha
bunch of et employees to are taking this
with me let's see how this so it's
called Carolina Reaper madness it says
on the back and not for the faint of
heart or stomach it is made from the
Carolina Reaper pepper which I believe
is the hottest pepper in the world
in the Guinness Book of World Records
it's supposed to be very very spicy and
I don't like spicy things at all if chip
comes in like a coffin that doesn't
sound good
very cute 2.5 grams of chip is 10
calories total fat point 5 this is
basically good for you
do you dare it to go to hell and back I
mean ok I've given birth I know what's
up here there's a fear the reaper thing
on it I'm just taking a very small
amount
it smells like regret in color it looks
like a Dorito it has these tiny little
dark spots
okay the whole thing going into my body
I'm gone pointer don't breathe
it's like the more you breathe the heart
more it hurts it doesn't just hit you
just yet it's not pleasant you know when
you're going to the dentist and you get
a shot of Novocain
and there's that split-second before it
actually takes effect and you're like
this is the worst decision I have made
in my life
that's what it feels like right now
that's are better that's like oh the
aftertaste really gets you though
okay I get a little bit of milk a little
hard to keep talk like a cat it's like
scratching onto my tongue this is pretty
good I wonder if it's gonna kick in like
really hard eventually okay it doesn't
really help the milk doesn't really help
the milk makes it worse Oh make it stop
does the honey do stuff but honey tastes
nice uh I think it's if I have more I
think it'll it'll really like start to
burn oh and I bet I have pepper on my
fingers oh and now it's in my sinuses
childbirth I did have an epidural I felt
nothing I feel things with this huh
that's a good level of spice I'm
actually gonna die eating this chip what
hell is really don't like that I think
this is really bad all right I'm gonna
go away
Oh God if I could think right now I
would probably have regrets Tom my
coworkers I'm very sorry let it go I
give it ten out of ten you killed it
died for pretzels on myself earlier I
kind of blacked out I'm gonna bop boom
what's the spiciest thing you guys have
ever eaten let us know in the comments
and don't forget to hit subscribe for
more videos like a pencil button